it's time for our scene and unseen
segment will we reveal the stories
behind the headlines and for that we
turn to fox news contributor author of
the forthcoming wise men who found
christmas raymond arroyo raymond the
president was out touting his cancer
moon shot yesterday in boston well what
is it well it's just a rebranding laura
of things the federal government's
already doing now critics say the
administration have requested no new
funding for this moonshot but that
didn't stop biden from selling it harder
than anything anything anything there's
nothing
nothing
nothing beyond our capacity our capacity
and uh
jack
jake i should say i'll use my
authorities as president to increase
funding to break law jam break log jams
into speed breakthroughs i announced the
new head of the national cancer
institute
boston's own
boston zone monika
bertalia bertinale excuse me i'll give
you my word as a biden this cancer
moonshot
is one of the reasons why
i ran for president
now blunders aside laura this is very
curious given the history of the biden
cancer initiative now this was founded
by jill and joe biden in 2017. the
bidens basically hired the obama cancer
moonshot staff and pharma lobbyists and
paid them hundreds of thousands of
dollars annually during the two years it
was running the bidens took in nearly
five million dollars in donations
according to the new york post they
spent more than three million on
salaries and zero on grants zero toward
cancer research this was a moon shot to
nowhere laura
well as someone who's a cancer thriver
myself i find that disgusting and
typical and not surprising from a family
of grifters what else outrageous well
the first lady was asked today about her
husband running in 2024 after the
performance you saw what do you make of
this
have you talked about it with him
not yet we've been a little bit too busy
not yet but i'm sure it'll be a
discussion look at the look at all joe
has done he has kept true to what he
said he would do and
so i think he just needs to keep going
look at all he's done laura the unity
he's brought the inflation he's brought
down restored americans place in the
world safety and security but i love how
she says he needs to keep going if only
he knew where he was going this was the
president yesterday after one of his
speeches he's the poor man look he's
totally confused doesn't know which way
to go and note the handheld mic he uses
now laura to compensate for his
diminished voice and when the prompter
went down yesterday at a different
speech
so did the speech look
the fact is that there's a lot a lot we
can do a lot we have to do
you know
the fact is that
right now
with this infrastructure law america is
uh
is really getting on the move again
oh my gosh oh laura this if it wasn't
our country it would be really funny but
this is
this it's a trap i mean he's like the
press secretary if you can't read it or
see it he's completely lost laura this
is heartbreaking i have to say how can
he run again how can he keep going
because jill will take him to wilmington
and
do whatever they do there to get them
ready for the next week i don't know go
ahead ray what else oh and this is my
recharge all right i have to read now
i'm getting like biden
okay
your mayor in new orleans uh latoya
can't trail she's a wonderful person and
she's facing i guess some backlash
though over her luxury travel what is
that yeah
laura there's a city ordinance here that
requires employees to fly coach and to
reimburse new orleans for any upgrade
now american trail went to the south of
france this summer she racked up more
than 30 thousand dollars in upgrades
since 2021 and she's refusing to give
any of the money back
all expenses incurred doing business on
behalf of the city of new orleans will
not be reimbursed to the city of new
orleans one thing is clear i do my job
and i will continue to do it with
distinction with dignity and integrity
every step of the way and so
that's what i have to say on that
yeah well laura this is why there's a
recall effort here in new orleans for
against mayor cantrell and 55 of new
orleanians in a new poll support that
recall that's bad news for the mayor but
when you're the murder capital of the
country you got to expect a recall
how many police officers are they down
in uh new orleans i mean only about 900
laura i'm just glad she got one of those
pods it's much better to travel in the
pod than with the hoi polloi so raymond
she needed that for her security so many
people recognized her security was in
the basement yeah they they needed the
security for her all right raymond great
to see you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else